alejandro was curious if sample median
was an unbiased estimator of population
median
he placed ping-pong balls numbered from
zero to 32 in a drum and mixed them well
note that the median of the population
is 16.
he then took a random sample of five
balls and calculated the median of the
sample he replaced the balls and
repeated this process for a total of 50
trials
his results are summarized in the dot
plot below where each dot represents the
sample median from a sample of five
balls so this right over here is a
sampling distribution of the sample
median you have a population of balls we
know a parameter we know that the median
of the population is 16. this right over
here is the population
and then he keeps taking samples of five
balls
so that is five ball sample right over
there and then he calculates the
statistic the median of the sample so he
calculates
the median there then he does it again
he calculates the median then he does it
again he calculates the median and then
he does this 50 times he does this 50
times and so what you see plotted right
over here you see 50 dots every time he
took a sample of five balls and
calculated the median we see that is one
of the dots here so for example four
times he calculated a median of 20. two
times he calculated a median of 19. one
time he calculated a median of four
now they ask us based on these results
does the sample median appear to be a
biased or unbiased estimator of the
population median so pause this video
and see if you can come up with an
answer to that
in order to be an unbiased estimator and
that is what you want your estimator to
be you want it to be unbiased the
sampling distribution for that statistic
has to be evenly distributed about the
true parameter for the population so for
example in this situation the true
parameter for the population they say
note that the median of the population
is 16. so that's the thing that you're
trying to estimate so this is where the
median of the population is
and so if we look at the sampling
distribution we see that it is roughly
balanced on to the left and to the right
of that true parameter so i would say
that this this is looking pretty
unbiased because
the sampling distribution is evenly
balanced to the left and the right of
the true median of the population that
true parameter if for some reason the
distribution looked something like this
then it would not be
unbiased or if the distribution looked
something like this if the distribution
if the distribution looked like this if
our sampling distribution was like this
this would mean that we're consistently
underestimating the true parameter and
if our distribution looked like this
this means that our statistic is
overestimating the true parameter let's
do another example
the dot plots below show an
approximation to the sampling
distribution for three different
estimators of the same population
parameter
if the actual value of the population
parameter is 5
which dot plot displays the estimator
with both low bias and low variability
pause this video and see if you can come
up with the answer
so the population parameter that we're
trying to estimate is five so let's show
that on each of these distributions
these approximations of the sampling
distributions
so
well over here we have our scale but
this should be one two three four five
six seven and one two three four five
six seven
and so our population parameter is five
so that is right over there that is
right over there and that this is right
over here
so which of these which of these
statistics seems to be biased let's just
start there pause this video which of
these look biased to you
well the one that looks clearly biased
is statistic c when you look at its
sampling distribution it is consistently
to the left of our true parameter so
it's consistently underestimating our
parameters so this one right over here
is biased
now statistic a and statistic b both
look reasonably unbiased remember these
are approximations of the sampling
distribution if you want to get closer
and closer to the sampling distribution
the true sampling distribution you would
keep taking samples and keep calculating
the statistic and keep plotting them on
this distribution right over here but
for statistic a it looks reasonably
balanced to the left and the right it's
not perfectly balanced but it's
reasonable remember these are
approximations and statistic b is also
reasonably balanced to the left and the
right
now they don't just say which one has a
low bias but they also say low
variability i would say both statistic a
and statistic b have relatively low bias
but if we talk about low variability
that's how much spread do they have
especially around the true parameter and
it looks like statistic a has much lower
spread than statistic b right over here
statistic b you've calculated statistics
that are two away from the true
parameter while in statistic a you've
calculated a statistic of certain
samples that are roughly half away from
the true parameter so the statistic that
has both low bias and low variability
that would be statistic a